hi everyone I'm Paul yep I'm a clinical
biochemistry receiver Health Sciences
Center and also from the University of
Toronto I'd like to thank the organizers
lab roots for organizing the clinical
Diagnostics virtual event and for
inviting me to talk about the role of
personally testing and achieving global
outcomes very single goal in 8 1 C and
also once you mentioned that November is
Diabetes Awareness Month so this is
great timing here are my learning
objectives I'm going to state the
benefits of an accuracy based
proficiency testing scheme for tingled
anyone seen and also to understand the
traceability of a1c assays to the NGS p
and to the isis and reference methods so
just as we build up i am going to
describe the burden of diabetes that
we're facing as a worldwide epidemic
this is a problem from bos and
developing in the US alone there's 34
million people that's nine point four
percent of the population that have
diabetes some of them are diagnosed but
a large number also undiagnosed and it's
also really significant because 1.3
million new cases came about in 2017 and
there's going to be another million and
so on after that in Canada it affects
more than 3.4 Canadians and a statistic
that we like to use here is that more
than 20 people are being newly diagnosed
with the disease every hour of every day
and if you actually look at the u.s.
numbers that is even bigger that's like
well over 100 so this is a very
significant problem so diabetes of
course has been defined by blood sugar
levels and blood sugar is the East
standard because this is this is what is
measured and what the body has
difficulty controlling while when there
is diabetes and so that has been the
mainstay of testing now a1c has come on
board or the
pastilla well and it's more indirect way
of measuring blood sugar and so here are
some of the differences between a1 C and
like glucose measurement so a1 C
represents an average glucose over the
previous two to three months or as blood
sugar really just the immediate number
now both values can vary physiologically
now the advantage of a1c is that is less
affected by acute stress and also a
large number of common drugs so while
there is some physiologic variation it's
not as much as blood glucose levels
which certainly go up and down certainly
throughout the day before and after
meals both are predictive of disease so
it is a very useful body mark and that
was art the a1c become so prominent well
there's no patient preparation required
there's no fasting that needs to be done
prior to the test on top of that the
sample itself is stable whereas if you
are doing a blood sugar measurement
you'd have to make sure that it was
collecting the lower two and make sure
that there's no breakdown on the
children so overall there is a huge
convenience for measuring diabetes for
measuring a1c as opposed to blood
glucose now there are some caveats we're
not measuring the sugar directly we're
measuring sugar that's attached to
hemoglobin molecule so if there are
disorders that have to do with your red
blood cells or any diseases all that may
affect the red cells in your body or the
woman in your body that could have an
impact they want some measurements so
come on to on the spotlight well this
goes back to some of the very early
trials such as the DC CT trial and that
showed when anyone seen levels work or
kept to a low number that would reduce
the risk from the microvascular
complications of type diabetes and so
these complications
la piscine nephropathy neuropathy and
alchemy area so it's not you know just a
black or white on a number you can see
that there is a scale that as you lower
the anyone see this reduces the relative
risk of those micro vascular
complications and so I put an arrow
there for the 7% because this is the
common targeted treatment for those with
diabetes and you can see that
significantly reduces the on to other
trials such as the UK PBS which was for
type 2 diabetes and so these are the
really important clinical trials watch
which our results for a1c pebble
established guidelines now include
various targets for anyone seen right
and so treatment has been long long
established views of a1c but more
recently the diagnostic utility of a1c
has been introduced so the diagnosis of
diabetes was introduced into the 88
guidelines in 2010 and that similarly
came at the same time as the
recommendation for screening using
labels we test now in other parts of the
world such as in Canada the adoption us
who notices came into the Canadian
recommendations of home 11 and then the
screen 13 now the World Health
Organization has recommended the use of
a1 C for diagnosis but not as yet for
the screening now beneath that table
I've shown some of the targets so the
treatment target has been long
established in both type 1 and type 2
diabetes
now the diagnostic target applies to
type 2 diabetes and type 2 is actually
the much
larger proportion of diabetics about
like 90 to 95 percent of diabetics have
type 2 and that's where we have this
worldwide epidemic and so the diagnostic
cutoff is at a level of 6.5% of higher
now in terms of screening there are
different guidelines that are out there
so you know all the diagnostic cutoff at
risk for developing diabetes or you
could be having pre-diabetes which is
impaired fasting glucose or Incas
glucose impaired glucose tolerance and
so the range is vary depending on the
national guideline that you're using but
one needs to remember that was your call
in the previous slide the risk of
diabetic complications actually follows
a continuum so even below the diagnostic
threshold of 6.5 there is a risk for
future development of diabetes or those
diabetic complications so all of these
these numbers are very relevant so the
use of a one seen for the diagnosis of
diabetes is now a universal standard and
that was defined in the 2011 wh children
report that recommended the use of a you
want sleep and what I want to highlight
in the record recommendation here is
that it can be used as a diagnostic test
for diabetes provided that stringent
quality assurance tests are in place and
asses are standardized two criteria
airline to international values and so
this is where the role of proficiency
testing has as well helped to ensure
that the use of a1c in the diagnosis
continues to be reliable so that brings
us into the learning objectives for the
first part I want to go through the
benefits
accuracy based proficiency testing
scheme for hemoglobin a1c so we have
proficiency testing so for those who are
working in a clinical environment and as
a part of laboratory accreditation there
is a requirement to perform proficiency
testing so for example the College of
American Pathologists has a lab
accreditation program where those were
born or you follow the ISO one five one
eight nine standard for medical
laboratories requirements to quality
competence in section five point six
point three laboratories shall perform
interlaboratory comparisons now the
first adjusting is also indirectly
stated within the diabetes downlines so
in the caning guidelines it says to be
the standardized validated assays on the
american guidelines that says to use a
method that is certified by the n - SP a
traceable to a DCC the acid so it
doesn't really say for instance a
testing outright but what this does
imply is that we implemented a method
that is validating well it seems to be
reliable throughout the lunch of the
test and so the way to do that is the
conditions of testing now I also am very
aware that in West there are some
upcoming changes to CLIA and whereby one
of the proposed changes is to make a one
C a regulated analyte meaning all the
Laura Tori's often the tests must
participate in an a1c proficiency
testing program and so there's there's
lots of discussion going on in the
internet I won't go into it
but I do encourage you to take a look
but hope you will find from today's
presentation that an accuracy based
teaching program as long as the final to
provide that rigorous quality assurance
program around your tables and testing
so what's so important about
thing this goes beyond merely just an
exchange of samples between the board
tours there are very important rules
around on proficiency testing it
formalizes the comparison of results
between the bruh Tories and consist of
scheduled challenges it also consists of
blinded samples and these are not just
blind it but they're not to be
communicated so this is truly what it is
like to test a pinching sample PT also
allows for clinically relevant
concentrations so that you're testing
the entire range of your hace it should
mimic patient samples in terms of how
they're handled ideally it checks the
entire process so not just the
analytical component but impossible to
create and post analytical steps as well
there's a predetermined performance
criteria so there are limits to which
the results must agree among all the
different participant and your results
both against other users of the same
test but you can also look for trends
than likely happening over time now if a
laboratory were outside of those
performing limits this is where
correction or corrective actions would
be necessary so this is actually key to
a quality assurance program so what are
some of the goals or a1c testing I'll
break this down into two parts on the
first is imprecision and so wait some
time ago
quality goals were specified by the ABA
the ACC and NAC V such that the
imprecision within a lab and between
labs which barely typed and so an
interlaboratory goals are in position
with the acedia quest which plan and
your own laboratories
all should be a city of less than 2% now
they had also defined an all method goal
of a CV less than 3.5% and this took
quite some time to to accomplish and a
CV of less than 3.5 was was first done
in 2016 and probably it was last in 2018
when it was consistently a served in
multiple samples from the TV programs so
now that's a precision has been has been
significantly improved over time what
about the total allowable error so the
current standard on proficiency testing
is that a method can achieve a total
allowable error of 6 percent using a
accuracy based grading scheme right and
actually we will be changing this to 5
percent in 2020 and manufacturers are
already certifying their instruments in
order to meet this 5 percent total our
total total allowable error goal so
before we go into specific aspects of TT
you know let's say I do a quick
refresher of exactly what is hemoglobin
a1c and so glucose that's in circulation
enters our red blood cells is taken up
by the red blood cells and it can attach
itself to the hemoglobin molecule so on
the left hand side this is mrs.
Illustrated you know by the uptake of
the glucose and on the right hand side
I've done to you well attaches itself
that's going to change in the first step
there's a reversible reaction and then
in the second step there's an
irreversible reaction
and so hemoglobin a1c is the stable
group of addict of the n-terminal valine
of the data beta chain so what's
important here is that you can see how
the structure of a1c changes but that
n-terminal aiming which would have been
positively charged you know now has been
utilized because of the glucose on it so
these are very important things to
consider given that there are many
different athletes to measure of angle C
so a1c is measured by number of
different approaches I've grouped them
here according to the principle and so
methods that are based on the charge
separation of encoding and see an
exchange sorry ion exchange hdl-c
capillary electrophoresis and mass
spectrometry on the other hand there are
methods that separates the hemoglobin
based on structure and so these include
affinity chromatography enzymatic assays
and amino acids so from this we have
various quantitative methods for
measuring a one-state so I also want to
remind you about the importance of
accuracy and precision follow when it
comes to diagnostic testing so these are
familiar or bullseye diagrams which I
hope you seen before because to
precision accuracy and so when we're
talking about precision we're talking
about the agreements between the peanut
measurements on the same specimen so
here on the Left bullseye you can see
that there is good precision here the
points when measured
over and over again are landing in
fairly safe spot now what we really want
is an accurate asset
okay so accuracy is the agreement
between the measured value and true
value so here in this bullseye you can
see that the different test results are
centered around the target so here you
know if you took the average of these we
could say that it's reasonably
reasonably accurate but because each
time you're it's not precise so ideally
the test is both accurate and precise
we're bifurcated measurements are
landing on the target every time you're
doing the test so this is important when
we're considering a1c but there's also
another caveat that we have to keep in
mind we have to make sure that our
assays have no interference from other
species that are present in the sample
and these may be related or unrelated
molecules so we need specificity as well
and so some bat stays very 1c are more
specific than others now why is
precision important well we have to
consider the source sources of
imprecision and so this can come from
analytical variation so this is the
testicle variation so these two come
together because these contribute to the
overall variation of the test and so
what's important when we're looking at
the trending our results is that we want
to make sure that the test itself can
identify a real change value in a1c so
we want to keep the analytical variation
as low as possible so that we see the
difference between between two
successful results is actually due to a
real
change physiologically so in order to
minimize analytical variation Aladdin
allowed needs to control the sources so
we want to make sure that the variation
between the instruments and the
operators is minimized not between
changes in the calibrator and reagent
Lots if we have a marginal boardshort we
have multiple instruments or proxy
perfect will denies the variation
between those two publications and
certainly for serial monitoring we want
to make sure that these are stable over
time so variation is important to
monitoring it's also important because
if we're going to use a diagnostic
cutoff we want to make sure that the
error around it digitally cut off is
minimized as well so that's where you
know we want to make sure the tests are
accurate and so in a patrician C testing
program we want to make sure that we
have the right target now for the most
part were used to per crystal to testing
where were rated by peer groups and so
character of assessment can be palpable
because it can give us the imprecision
of a particular method and you know
results may be within your peer group
okay but that doesn't mean that your
results are necessarily will be accurate
so for example we can have for good plus
or minus some limit you can Method B
will be a different target for that peer
group with its limit and there could
also be CG or any number of other users
in the survey but how do we know that
all of them are agreeing with each other
and so if we're going to measure a one C
using Universal cut-offs while we need a
gold standard or electricity testing so
another important consideration is the
right material and when we're
considering quality control and what
we're doing on the lab
we have made use of QC but it does come
with some limitations we have QC that is
stable lasts for a long time and we're
able to make sure nothing is working
correctly but probably has a different
matrix than an actual patient sample it
probably has preservatives in there and
may even be modified so oftentimes we
have lightweight multi analytic you see
it may be subject to manipulation
whereby we might need to freeze it or
reconstitute a localized acusa material
and so on so kisi material is not ideal
for monitoring accuracy we also set our
own houston targets and so although we
might have a very good form method we
know that there's other variation going
on such as law changes awkward changes
and so on and so our QC might be
adjusted to reflect those changes and
that might actually make our QC targets
blinder okay because at the end of the
day we want to make sure that you know
we have to either go on with the testing
or we have been troubleshooting and we
don't want to set per QC too light too
tight that leads to needless
troubleshooting so for accuracy based
proficiency testing we actually need
something that reflects at the right
material and so we would ideally have a
sample that you would treat much like a
patient sample and so in an accuracy
based scheme it would use a fresh cold
blood sample and this properties of
commute ability meaning that when you
test it on one system or another system
it's going to behave in the same way
whereas if you use some other taking
material that has been like like frozen
or localized or somehow treated even
though it might be the same sample those
modifications could actually lead to
different results great you want to
compare them to a true breakfast of
oratory so in this case we're talking
about on the board short that is
certified to actually give a reference
value or anyone see
so here I've given a snapshot of a
peachy program from the College of
American Pathologists you can actually
find this data on the NGS P website and
I you know don't want to to overwhelm
you with all these numbers but you can
see here that in this particular survey
there were actually five challenge
samples six seven eight nine and ten
and you can see that it also gives a
summary of the method performance across
different assets so there's assays that
have shown on the left hand side here so
peachy can actually go beyond just
looking at your own results and seeing
if you're you're within the limits it
can actually be get a lot of information
about how your particular method is
performing you can post with others and
what's useful in this particular example
is that it actually highlights you know
some meth is that you might need to keep
your eye on that you might be using this
method you might be considering changing
to this method and so in the top row
there's a number of grayed out bosses
that are showing higher than expected
imprecision in comparison to those
global log balls that I just slide in
the lower box there's another method
that actually has a bias and the device
is clearly alarmed but it is something
that might give you a bit of a warning
sign
especially since it came up in a couple
of the samples and so T is actually a
very powerful quality indicator so they
can actually kind of signal or some some
changes that that one needs to be aware
of and possibly take some proactive
steps so that brings me to a second part
of this presentation and that's to give
you a few slides so that we can
understand the traceability of a1c
assays to the NGS P and to the IOC's
department's networks so the NGS p
formally known as the National
glycohemoglobin standardization program
now it is known as the NGS P and if
you're interested in reading in more
detail the next one review that came out
this year in clinical chemistry that
that highlights the work that's been
done over the past twenty years so the
role of the NGO speak is to ensure that
there is traceability to the clinical
outcomes of the DCC trial so even though
that that ended the vacuum back in the
90s those targets that were cest are
still being used now the engines he also
certifies the methods for hemoglobin a1c
it also defines the acceptable
performance limits for the manufacturers
it also plays a very important role in
proficiency testing by assigning the
value this is the target value for the
different samples in the program and
lastly both the and the value assignment
for PT programs is it accuracy graded
using threshold blood samples and this
is one of the figures taken from that
trends and it really shows how we 1c
methods have improved substantially from
the from the time the DCT trial ended to
today and you can see back at the very
beginning on the ph.d program the
methods that are around showed enormous
variability so the dashed line
represents the target value set by the
ng SP and you can see that some of the
methods even overlap the NTSB target
that was just you know too much you know
falsely high able to see results no
there's a more on target and once we get
you know into 2010 when the diagnostic
utility they won't see was introduced
there was fairly good agreement you can
see that the methods are now generally
in line with the NGS be target and also
the slides of the error bars is much
tighter and so in 2010 the allowable
error was actually it was actually
reduced by half I'm going at 15%
you know down to it to 8% and now when
you fast forward to 2018 this this is
where we currently have our six percent
allowable error goal and that's going to
be further tightened
they can see how that performance
continues to accrue so the I FCC has
played an important role in the global
standardization of a1c results so the
has allowed the traceability to the
trials plus at the time on the reference
method was based on a cation exchange
chromatography now in terms of the rule
of minus TC ICC has played an important
role in terms of helping to fulfill they
need you correctly
and that is the traceability of the
values assigned to calibrators while
more control materials must be assured
through available reference measurement
procedures or reference materials of a
higher order so back in the eighties and
nineties there you know was no higher
order reference material or higher order
reference method for a1c so a higher
order rushes through 2003 and now
manufacturers actually certified their
methods with the calibration that's
traceable to the ISTC method and in
order to to convert the ISTC units which
are the moles per mole there's an
equation that relates the ICC values
back to the NGS P minutes so here in
North America we are maintaining the use
of NGS P units but in other parts of the
Europe in the other person the world in
Europe some countries have started to
adopt the eyes asleep measurements so
that will take some time but there is
ongoing now in my last slide there's
probably a number of you in the audience
thinking about well what about those
where we have to be very considerate of
having a reliable quality assurance
program now first off there are many
commercially available point-of-care
tests for Timo globin a1c and they are
also certified Baldwin's recipe but
where do we stand on this and so the
different countries have taken on a
different approach but a high like the
one that came from the ABA and so
anyway standards of medical care of the
2019 it did state that although
point-of-care a once the assays make the
NGS be certified or US FDA approved for
diagnosis proficiency testing is not
always mandated for performing the test
and therefore point of care as they
approved for diagnostic purposes should
only be considered instant license to
perform high compulsory testing and so
what this implies is that it would be
done in a accredited laboratory
environment and thereby have a
proficiency testing program to back it
up if it were completely point-of-care
in the context of the US where would be
obeyed test then the physical testing
would not be mandated so you can see
that there is an important role that
positions in tested proficiency testing
has and making sure that a 1c assays are
able to uphold this diagnostic utility
so I'm going to finish off and just
summarize all of what I've presented to
you and so first proficiency testing for
globin a1c is a vital part of quality
assurance and a requirement for
laboratory accreditation based
proficiency test a 1c results positive
outcomes and the detection and treatment
of patients with diabetes
lastly global efforts to standardize
Ebola can evolve and a 1 C results has
enabled and sustained in treatments from
the consistency of a1c results worldwide
and with that I have reached the end of
my talk if you are watching on the
November 14th I want to wish you a happy
world Diabetes Day and also I would like
you to be aware that November is
national
these awareness month I thank you for
attention and certainly you can contact
me to my email address called on give at
you Chandra dossier if you have any
questions thank you